foreign
[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
Bible related question give us a call
now at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor
welcome listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
in 1969 a well-groomed 74 year old
gentleman was jumped from behind as he
walked down 53rd Street in New York City
the muggers had the surprise of their
lives as the old man broke loose spun
around and proceeded to knock both of
his assailants flat with his fists
leaving them sprawled on the sidewalk
they might have thought twice if they
had known the old man they had singled
out as an easy target was a former
professional boxer
but not just any boxer but the Ferocious
world heavyweight boxing champion Jack
Dempsey he was known as one of the
toughest boxers in history and a hero
for the likes of Muhammad Ali and Mike
Tyson
when later asked by reporters Dempsey
replied I guess I was just acting out of
instinct
he knew how to fight in a pinch because
he had practiced in real life
you know the Bible says every believer
must train to fight the good fight of
Faith against the attacks of the devil
you know you can read about that in
first Timothy Pastor Ross where it says
in chapter 6 fight the good fight of
Faith lay hold on eternal life to which
you were also called and have confessed
a good confession in the presence of
many witnesses
uh sometimes people are told that you
know once you accept Jesus
everything's going to be fine they don't
really understand that there's going to
be struggles the Christian walk
sometimes involves battles that says we
run we wrestle we War we strive and
people need to know that there's a fight
and you can train in preparation for a
fight that's right Pastor Doug you know
before an army goes into battle they go
into training they call it boot camp and
they prepare so that they can be
successful in battle and as Christians
there is preparation that we can do so
that we can be successful in the most
important Battle of all often in the
Bible the Christian and the church is
likened unto a soldier and an army and
we're fighting in the Lord's cause not
fighting against flesh and blood but
against principalities and Powers as
Paul puts it how can we resist the
assaults of the devil well we have a
book it's called tips for resisting
temptation if you've made a decision to
be a Christian you know about Temptation
because the devil does not want people
to follow the will of God to keep his
Commandments how can we be victorious in
our life we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks the book is
called tips for existing Temptation the
number is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for offer
number seven five zero or just ask for
it by name it's called tips for existing
Temptation and if you have a smartphone
you can just dial pound 250 and say
Bible answers live and then ask for the
book tips for resisting temptation and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
out there you know Pastor Doug it's so
important that we as Christians as you
mentioned in the beginning recognize
that once a person gives their life to
Christ the battle isn't over it's really
beguning Earnest and if ever we need the
armor of God and the spirit within us
it's living the Victorious Christian
Life yeah and that's one of the messages
throughout scripture from Joshua to
Gideon to David that there are battles
involved but if you're fighting in God's
battle he gives you strength and he'll
give you victory
well before we go to the phone lines as
we always do we would like to begin the
program with prayer dear father we thank
you that we have this opportunity once
again to study your word we know that
the Bible is like committed to the sword
that the Christian needs when he battles
against the forces of Darkness so we
pray that you guide us as we open up
your word and study together and we
thank you in Jesus name amen amen
opacity we also want to welcome all of
those who are joining us I know we have
folks who are watching on AF TV also
listening on the radio are those who are
listening are also on Facebook the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page the amazing
facts Facebook page all sort Amazing
Facts YouTube and on AF TV I think I
mentioned that and some who are watching
on Hope Channel
so we'd like to welcome all of those who
are participating in this live
interactive International Bible study
and if you have a Bible question a phone
line here to the studio is
800-463-7297 it's
800-463-7297 800 God says and that'll
bring you here into the studio with your
Bible question our first caller this
evening is Anthony listening in New York
Anthony welcome to the program
Anthony you're on the air good evening
Pastor yeah
um
uh my question
is based on Exodus chapter 8 verses 22
and 23. and um I guess the question is
why do the Israelites have to suffer the
first three plagues and why did God Only
You Know make a division between the
Israelites and the Egyptians on the
fourth plague well another way to say
that that's very interesting is why did
God then deliver them from the seven
last plagues and if you look in
Revelation of course God delivers his
people during the seven last plagues in
Revelation
but I think one reason is because God
reminds us that people suffer as a
result of decisions of others none of
the Israelites were in Egypt because of
a decision they had made they were
suffering because of a decision their
ancestors had made
and why are we suffering in a world of
sin people suffer because of a decision
our ancestors made going all the way
back to Adam and Eve and and
subsequently subsequently others since
them so I think God is illustrating that
you know even in a war even innocent
people suffer
and so yes they did experience the first
three plagues and they were not the most
catastrophic part of the plague the
plagues started uh easy you might say
they got tougher and tougher as it went
along
you know we do have a study guide that
talks about the origin of evil and why
we live in a world with sin and why do
good people sometimes suffer the study
guide is called did God create a devil
and it talks about the origin of evil
it's a great study guide it's part of
our set of amazing facts study guides
again we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747 or dial pound 250 you can
say Bible answers live and then ask for
the study guide It's called did God
create a devil and of course we'll send
that to anyone here in the U.S in North
America Canada thank you for your call
Anthony we got Gary listening in
Illinois Gary you're on the air
hi my question is are we living in the
Book of Revelation I get this from
Matthew 24 you'll see plagues and
pestilence wars and rumors and Wars
these are the beginning of Sorrows and
Revelation 8 7. the world will end by
fire and Hell Fire everything west of
the Rocky Mountains 75 wildfires going
on for six months it took to put them
out and then hail you go to YouTube
hailstorm Georgia Texas France uh they
show you hail storms ties of baseballs
going through windshields and so even
now uh atmospheric Rivers we never had
that 10 five years ago this is all new
stuff
so that's my question
well in a word yes we are living in the
Book of Revelation because Revelation
the prophecies actually begin with he
says the time is at hand so Revelation
is covering a span of history from the
first coming to the second coming of
Jesus and so we're definitely living in
the time of Revelation and I think we
are also living in the time of Matthew
24.
um there have always been Wars as a
matter of fact Jesus said there'll be
wars and rumors of wars but the end is
not yet in other words don't let every
war that comes along make you think this
is the end but what you would see as you
got closer to the end is that the wars
and the natural disasters and
earthquakes and the plagues and
pestilence would increase in intensity
and frequency Jesus talks about it as
birth pangs and when a woman's about to
have a baby you start the contractions
and as the contractions get closer
together they get more intense and then
you've got a baby eventually
so that's what's happening is that as we
near the end of time it's almost like a
uh a top as it's about to fall over it
begins to gyrate and wobble and our
whole planet is sort of gyrating right
now Paul says the whole creation groans
and travails together and so I do think
you've seen an increase the last world
wars in the last century
were unprecedented and now we've got
weapons and you know if if Russia uses
one of its nuclear weapons and how many
other countries have nuclear weapons now
Pakistan and India and Israel and France
and all over the world yeah Mark the end
that's why Jesus said except those days
be short and no flesh would be saved you
know I'm thinking of a verse pasted in
Luke chapter 21 and verse 25 this is
what it says it says there will be signs
in the sun and the moon and the stars
and on the earth the stress of nations
with perplexity and it says the Sea and
the waves roaring kind of get the idea
of tornadoes and storms verse 26 says
and man's Hearts failing them for fear
and the expectation of those things
which are coming upon the Earth for the
powers of heaven will be shaken so here
we have a description of end time events
and it talks about natural phenomenon
storms in the sea perplexities distress
amongst Nations fear disease all of
these things we see happening today and
of course also referred in the Book of
Revelation yep absolutely so I think the
answer to that question is yes we are
living in the last days do we know the
day and the hour no can we tell when
that time is near yes Jesus said when
you see these things begin to come to
pass lift up your heads for your
Redemption draws nigh or draws near
thank you appreciate your call Gary
we've got Judith listening in Nevada
junith welcome to the program hello
hello Pastor dog and Professor generals
right can you hear me yes we do hello
yeah you're on we hear you
you're on the air
uh junip can you hear us okay well can
you hear me a beatbox your dog yes can
you hear me hello
you think she may have her phone muted
and she hears us on the radio right okay
all right we'll come back to to Jonathan
just a minute we've got Martha listening
in California Martha welcome to the
program
yes you're on the air
I lost you
yeah you're here can you hear us
hello
well we may have some technical problems
if two people in a row can't hear us
yeah we might have lost two people uh
let's try and go back to who do we have
next we're going to try Glenn hopefully
this one will work uh Glenn in Ohio Glen
can you hear us hey good evening from
Brazil Ohio
just wanted to tell you I enjoy the
program getting different answers on
common issues well I think he was
looking for an answer or the issue
that's not very common
okay you know today is being more and
more seen the Jewish people are being
cross-lighted into Christianity
as I get to see in the mail that it's
really on the increase but in my Bible
studies and searching scriptures I went
to the scripture Zechariah
verses 28 I'm sorry 22 and 23. Zechariah
Chapter 8. 22 and 23 which indicates
there might be a reversal of
prosely lighting there can you comment
on that go ahead
yes thank you very much we'll do our
best Glenn yeah in Zechariah it's saying
something you actually hear repeated
other places in the Bible where God
talks about that people will turn to the
god of the Jews of course this first
happened with Jesus when a Christian
comes to Christ it is not a rejection or
repudiation of Judaism
what it is is the Fulfillment of Judaism
all Judaism all look forward to the
coming of the Messiah and the first ones
who proclaimed the Messiah were all Jews
and the New Testament is written by Jews
and Paul said that what happens is when
a gentile accepts Christ they become a
spiritual Jew so what it's saying here
in Zechariah is that people of the world
would come to the god of Abraham Isaac
and Jacob and true Judaism Embraces the
true Messiah
so this is not there's nothing wrong
with Christians inviting Jews to accept
Jesus that's not asking them to renounce
or their Judaism it's actually a
fulfillment of that my mother's Jewish
and so I never felt like I was more
Jewish than after I accepted Jesus
because the Bible is like I felt like
it's our book you know and yeah so we we
appeal for Jews everywhere to accept
Jesus and Christians become spiritual
Jews you know we've done actually you
passed it again and two Jewish friends
of yours did a series of presentations
called is Jesus Kosher for the Jews yeah
and I think amazing facts has the DVD
people can call and ask for it it might
also be available on YouTube I'm not
sure probably on the Amazing Facts
website but we also have that book
called spiritual Israel that's right and
we could send a free copy to Glenn the
number to call for that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
called spiritual Israel you can also
dial pound 250 say Bible answers live
and then ask for the book spiritual
Israel I think if you call Glenn uh
let's see we've got uh Martha in
California we'll go back to Martha uh
Martha uh can you hear us
yes I can now
um just all of a sudden went blank
before
um my question uh by the way good
evening pastors and happy New Year
um my question comes from Genesis 15
verse 17. uh the Lord had asked Abraham
to lay out three different animals in a
two different birds and then later after
um Abraham had fallen into a deep sleep
there was a smoking furnace and a
burning lamp that passed
among the animals
um could you please let me know or tell
me
um what those two items represent
well when the the animals being divided
like that is a sacrifice and often
covenants were ratified with sacrifice
and God was making a covenant with
Abraham but he was also warning Ibrahim
that his people were going to go through
a time of severe trial which of course
was fulfilled in Egypt and he says to
him that you know your descendants will
be struggling in another land and
they'll be oppressed but the the smoking
fire that passed between the um the
sacrifice that was like the the glory of
God the consuming fire the Shekinah that
passed between them and I think it was
sort of a symbol of the presence of God
was going to be there and bring his
people through
it also referenced her Covenant when
somebody would back in Bible times if
they were to do something like that and
divide an animal and they let the blood
flow into a little bit of a trench and
those making an oath or a promise would
often pass through that and in essence
they are saying if if I fail to keep my
side of the agreement you know I can be
as those killed and here you have God in
this Burning Fire passing through the
midst of these sacrificed animals as if
God is saying you know you can put your
trust in me even though your descendants
are going to be in this foreign land for
400 years I will bring them back and the
whole promise of the Jewish people is
the coming of the Messiah so there's a
reference to Christ the promised one who
would deliver them ultimately from all
of the enemies spiritual enemies yeah
very good
all right well thank you for your call
Martha we've got Carol listening in
Nebraska Carol you're on the air
hello thank you for taking my call
um I have I have a question on Psalm 139
verse 16.
it says Thine Eyes did see my substance
yet being unperfect and in thy book all
my members were written which in
continuance were fashioned when as yet
there was none of them
zybook is that referring to the Book of
Life
uh you know I'm not sure that that would
be the Book of Life
um you know the Bible talks about a book
of remembrance I think that God is
basically just saying that
um our David is actually writing in the
psalm by the way what version were you
reading from because I was following
along and my Bible here is a little
different
uh was the King James okay that you were
reading from the King James
I was yeah okay well because I thought I
was following in the King James it says
in verse 17.
um or you were reading verse 16 rather
right
right uh-huh your eyes saw my substance
being yet unformed and in your book they
were all written the days fashioned for
me as yet when as yet there were none of
them
um yeah I think he's basically saying
God said to Jeremiah that uh I ordained
you a prophet from your mother's womb
and you know God is basically telling
his about his foreknowledge of each of
us in our lives so I don't know that it
was talking about the Book of Life
rather that God knows all things and he
had purposed or planned for his people
to accomplish it thanks
and that yeah God's got a plan for
everyone
so how many books are there I know
there's the book of life and book of
remembrance
um
how many other books are there in heaven
do you know yeah and keep in mind
um books in heaven are probably not like
what you'd find in the Smithsonian
Library
or the Library of Congress uh you know
God I think has a record of every word
we've ever spoken
and every deed that we do I think there
are angels that record all things
right now when you think about it in in
China they've got facial recognition
software that's monitoring about a
quarter of their people and they're
recording everything you think about how
the data that that involves well if
humans can do that how much can God do
well you know we do know that the Bible
has of course the Book of Life yeah
that's where the names of the redeemed
are you have the book of remembrance
which is a record of the Good Deeds that
were done and then of course you have
the book of sin or the book of iniquity
where Every Idle Word and that means
speak they shall give an account of so
but not Every Idle Word is sin yeah yeah
that's true yes I mean there's a book of
record a book of records yeah everything
is recorded in heaven yeah Jesus says
they shall give an account of it right
they have Reckoning so yeah of course
sins are recorded you're right yeah
there is the book of sin all right well
thank you Carol good question we've got
we're going to go back to Judith in
Nevada and hopefully we've got uh
everything's working can you hear us
can you hear me that's the dog yes
oh thank you thank you Jesus it's a
wonderful thing that um I'm in this
school
first of all Happy Blessed safe and
healthy New Year to the both of you well
thank you thank you for taking my call
my question is uh what made the Israel
the oh in the Old Testament time and
even uh going forward to the New
Testament time that they were described
by God as uh hard-headed and stiff-neck
people I already have my biblical
insights I want to have biblical
insights from the expert like you thank
you for answering my call
yeah I hope we never called ourselves
experts but uh I'll share with you what
we believe is I don't think that
um the Israelites were especially more
hard-headed than another Nation might be
I think it's the nature of sin uh who is
it Isaiah that tells us all we like
sheep have gone our own way
and the Lord laid on him the iniquity of
us all
so it's kind of the nature of the human
race the reason he called them a
stubborn and a stiff-neck People is he
said do not think I chose you because
you're better than other nations said
you are a stubborn and a stiff neck
people
um he said I chose you because of my
grace
so I don't think that the Lord was
saying Jews are a lot more stubborn and
stiff neck than other nations or other
races I think he was just illustrating
that it's he that you know he was
working especially with them but in
spite of all the Miracles they still
weren't getting it right and that
probably would have happened with any
Nation
you know junip I think you'd also like
the book of cold spiritual Israel the
number again is
800-835-6747 you can just ask for the
book it's called spiritual Israel you
can also press pound 250 on your phone
say Bible answers live and then ask for
the book spiritual Israel
uh next color that we have is calling
from New York we have Arvin uh calling
avian welcome yes hi good evening
pastors good evening it's avian
um my question has to do with Luke
chapter 12 verses 47 and 48. I want to
know if this text means that when at the
end of time when all the wicked are cast
into the Lake of Fire if some people
will burn more intensely than others
based on their sin
for example you know if Hitler who has
killed many people will burn longer at
that time
as I love someone who's killed one or
two let me read this for our friends
that are listening you you know what the
verse says but others don't if you look
in Luke chapter 12 verse 47 and that
servant who knew his master's will and
did not prepare himself to do according
to his will will be beaten with many
stripes but he who did not know yet
committed things deserving of Stripes
will be beaten with few for everyone to
whom much is given from him much will be
required and to whom much has been
committed of him they will ask them more
basically saying that we're accountable
based on what we know but one thing
that's clear there are varying degrees
of punishment and the Bible talks about
varying degrees of reward Jesus says for
those who are persecuted for
righteousness sake great is your reward
in heaven and so there are varying
degrees of punishment and reward because
God is a good judge and yes I think
clearly Hitler uh who is at least from
our understanding is a lot more guilty
than most people is going to suffer for
all of the misery and the guilt that he
caused and the one who will suffer the
most and the longest would no doubt be
the devil
of course the final penalty of sin the
Bible tells us is death but not everyone
will immediately die at least not you
know in that Lake of Fire there will be
different degrees of punishment that
will be meted out based upon the works
of the wicked Pastor that can we also
say that there's there's rewards in
heaven I know the reward of eternal life
is given to to all who are saved but in
addition to that those who have
sacrificed those perhaps who have spent
time as missionaries and you know have
martyred were martyred for their faith
are they also differing rewards in
heaven for the righteous yes yeah the
fact that he said the great is your
reward in heaven he emphasized that and
uh
yeah if he's going to have varying
degrees of rewards for punishment there
will be varying degrees of rewards
matter of fact the disciples said can I
sit on your right hand left hand and
Jesus said someone's going to have that
position but uh that's my father's going
to decide that and he told the Apostle
he says you'll sit on 12 Thrones with me
judging the 12 tribes so there's going
to be Thrones there's varying positions
in heaven and even among the Angels now
there are varying positions
all right very good next holiday we have
is Lee listening in Texas Lee welcome to
the program
yes sir thank you and happy New Year to
you Pastor Ross and Pastor Bachelor
thank you Happy New Year likewise
yes sir my my question is I am a dead
catch one of your mom early programs and
I believe about a man coming back to God
for all the wrong reasons and I think I
might be one of those among people that
that is coming back to my to God
because I mean I didn't really want to
come back to gun and then
just recently because um I didn't know
the truth about him a heaven or Eternal
fire or
Eternal parent I've been perishing
forever
and now that I now I know the truth
about it about
being completely destroyed that's what
turned me back to God but that's turning
back to God just out of
self-preservation not out of love for
God I mean I've I've been studying the
book of the Bible the King James version
yeah well let me jump in real quick
we're going to run out of time before a
mid uh mid-break there's not a wrong
reason to turn back to God a desire for
Heaven is normal that's what God tells
us about the reward wanting to avoid
punishment is also normal I mean we
teach children with simple things like
that they they get spanked or there's
some corporal punishment for bad
behavior as you mature you want your
children to obey because of principle
and as we mature as Christians we obey
God because we know he loves us and we
learn to trust him come back to him any
way you can do the right thing because
you know it is the right thing and say
Lord give me the right motives to do the
right thing along the way and he will
so take those first steps we have a book
we can send you called three steps to
Heaven we'd like to encourage you to
read that Lee the number to call for
that is just
800-835-6747 and again you can ask for
the book it's called three steps to
Heaven we'll send that to anyone who
calls and asks
yeah thank you very much friends this is
not the party music we're just taking a
break we're going to come back and we
hope you'll still call in with your
Bible questions and we'll look forward
to the second half of the program where
we study the word of God together
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
the U.S government is drowning in debt
to the tune of 22 trillion dollars but
before you wag your finger at the
government's spending the Federal
Reserve says the average American
household carries over a hundred and
thirty seven thousand dollars in debt
while it was never God's plan that we
live with a burden of death Proverbs 22
7 warns us the rich rules over the poor
and the borrower is servant to the
lender living with debt is a stressful
burden it actually hurts your
relationship with God in my new
pocketbook deliverance from debt I
outline the Bible principles on how to
properly manage your money with some
practical suggestions and how you can
get out and stay out of debt if you or
someone you love is drowning in debt
order a copy of Deliverance from debt
today it can be a lifesaver to keep you
from going under please call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
do you feel as though your world is
spiraling out of control or perhaps new
life challenges are frightening you more
than they should are you sinking while
you're thinking excessive worry can
consume you eating you from the inside
out resulting in sickness insomnia and
paralyzing fear it can also damage
relationships ruin opportunities and yes
diminish your witness for the gospel
worry affects everybody differently but
it's all driven by fear
so how can you overcome a world full of
reasons to be anxious
I'd like to recommend for you my new
book Finding peace in a world of worry
you'll discover a Lifeline to Victory a
place where you can cast your cares upon
Christ and experience a Serenity that
isn't subject to your circumstances send
the gift of any amount to receive your
copy of Pastor Doug's new book Finding
peace in a world of worry call
877-232-2871 today
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian Life call us now
at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now let's read join our
hosts for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and for anyone who has
tuned in along the way this is as the
title suggests a live International
Bible study and we invite you to call in
with your Bible questions we're also
streaming on Facebook you can go to the
amazing facts Facebook page or the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page and it's on
YouTube and it's on AF TV and being
rebroadcast and a number of other
television Outlets
but I think we have some questions
already queued up and so if you haven't
called in do you get in line right now
and we'll go back to the phones all
right our next caller that we have is
Carlos listening from Florida Carlos
welcome to the program
good evening pastors
evening
good evening we want to thank you both
you guys and you guys you guys provide a
wonderful service man God bless you guys
you guys are real blessing oh thank you
it's a pleasure
and your question
um so the question is uh so we are Faith
we're saved uh by grace through faith
correct yes not by work but
the face uh faith without works is dead
so I wanted to know if there's a way
to you know I you know
discern the two you know it seems like
it's a thin line
yeah well the sequence is I think the
key uh you look at the story in the
Bible and when the Lord saved the
children of Israel from Egypt
he did not save them because they had
done a lot of good works he saved them
because of Grace they sacrificed the
lamb the Passover Lamb and they began
their Journey out of Egypt they crossed
out of Egypt then he brings them to
Mount Sinai and he gives them the law
and he says I am the Lord who saved you
out of Egypt basically if you love me
keep my commandments so God Saves us
first and then his desire his hope is
that because of our love for him we'll
want to obey
so first you have the lamb then you have
the law
those who persisted in Disobedience
never made it to the promised land
the reason that we do the good works is
not to be saved but because we have been
saved
the Bible says we love him because he
first loved us we see his love for us we
want to love him and if we love him we
obey him
so I don't know if that's answering what
you're asking Carlos
it sort of helps uh there was another uh
young man who just asked a pretty
similar question he he was um he
mentioned that sometimes he feels like
he uh
he he his works are more like uh out of
fear of going to hell and that sort of
thing and I was wondering if does that
fall on what what works does that follow
me is that Faith or is that just like
worked by our own efforts to
you know get to heaven
yeah you know I think sometimes people
are left with the impression that it's
wrong to evaluate your behavior and to
try to do the right thing even if you
don't feel like it because you know it
is the right thing
there's nothing wrong with doing the
right thing for self-preservation you
know the the Lord he puts warnings in
the Bible because he knows it won't
respond to trying to do what's right the
best thing is to do what's right because
we trust him
but then we should also do what's right
because He commands it and he says there
are bad consequences if we disobey
so it is true that sometimes we'll do
the right thing and we're saying you
know am I behaving correctly and what if
I don't am I being Works oriented
well it's it's it's easy to get that
mixed up
um there's nothing wrong with evaluating
your Works Paul says Let each one of us
examine ourselves whether we're in the
faith prove your own selves don't you
know your own selves that's in second
Corinthians
so again I don't know if I'm answering
what you're asking but
um it's normal to evaluate yourself and
also to say I want to do the right thing
because I want to go to heaven I don't
want to be lost
But ultimately you want to do it because
you love God
you know we have a book pass today that
I think will help illustrate this it's
called The High Cost of the Cross that's
really the motivation of why a person
chooses to do the will of God it's
because we recognize the price that was
paid for our Salvation it's free we'll
send you this book anyone who calls and
asks the number to call these
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
book it's called The High Cost of the
Cross and we'll be happy to send it to
anyone in Canada or the us or in U.S
territories also you can just simply
dial pound 250 on your phone and we'll
ask say Bible answers live and then ask
for the book it's called The High Cost
of the Cross and of course we want to
also recognize those who are listening
outside of North America in different
countries around the world we want to
encourage you to go to our website just
amazingfacts.org all the resources that
we talk about on this program are
available right there at the Amazing
Facts website as well next caller that
we have is Henry listening in New York
Henry welcome to the program
uh yes how are you I'm a person New Year
thank you uh my question is uh
uh the sound when Christ from back
there's going to be a thousand year
reign uh for the people who are not fade
uh they moved over to join my family I
Reign uh is God giving them enough time
to to repent
yeah well during the Thousand-Year rain
sometimes called the Millennium during
that time when Jesus comes back
probation is closed at that point when
Christ Returns the Savior saved and the
lost or lost there is no Second Chance
beyond that
when the Lord descends from heaven it
says the wicked are destroyed by the
brightness of his coming
Peter says second Peter chapter 3 the
elements melt with fervent heat the
earth and the things in it are burned up
so
now is the time before Christ comes it's
appointed unto men once to die after
that the Judgment there is no Second
Chance once the Millennium begins so
people need to make the decision before
the Millennium begins you know we have a
study guide It's called a thousand years
of peace and it talks about that one
thousand year period spoken of in
Revelation chapter 20 sometimes called
the Millennium we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks the
number is
800-835-6747 ask for the study guide
It's called a thousand years of peace
and of course you can also just dial
pound 250 say Bible answers live and
then ask for the study guide a thousand
years of Peace next caller that we have
is Edith listening in Illinois Edith
welcome to the program
hello thank you for having me so I was I
understand Michael to be
um a station of Jesus or that's a that's
Jesus and as I was going through a study
with someone I was trying to explain
that but when we got to uh Daniel 10
chapter 13 where it says Michael one of
the chief princes they said it sounds
like he's more it's more than one Chief
friend so what is that referring to when
it says one of the chief princes yeah
that's a common misunderstanding the
word one there the word one can mean one
numerically and the one one can also
mean one is like a sequentially and
there it means sequentially so another
way you might translate it is Michael
first of the chief princes
uh you know when you say that uh the
president's wife is the first lady well
you don't mean she's the first lady that
ever came to the U.S or was born in the
U.S you just mean that there's a place
of prominence and so there would say
Michael
first our greatest of the princes
and uh it's not like he's one of many
and he died in chapter 12 verse 1 it
refers to Michael says the prince who
stands watch over the sons of your
people so there specifically it refers
to the prince that stands watch and his
name is Michael and not just calls him
the prince he calls them the great
Prince that's right in Daniel chapter 12
verse 1.
yeah we have a book called who is
Michael the Archangel we will send you
or anyone that wants to understand that
a free copy and of course friends if you
don't understand it that's not a
Salvation issue but I think it'll
enhance your Bible study to know who is
this Michael that appears in the Old and
New Testaments what does that mean is it
a special breed of angel
the number to call for that is
800-835-6747 and again you can just ask
for the book it's called Michael the
Archangel or who is Michael who is
Michael the Archangel dial pound 250 on
your smartphone say Bible answers live
and say I want the book Michael who is
Michael the Archangel and we'll be happy
to send it to anyone who calls and asks
we've got Raquel listening in California
Raquel welcome to the program
hi good afternoon
yeah how are you doing
thank you for asking my question um was
regarding
um I don't know of any verse um at least
um I'm barely starting to read the Bible
so I just want to I had a question
regarding if the devil Lucifer in heaven
um had a role pertaining to the choir
was he like in charge of the choir and I
asked this question this question
because it pertains to today's culture
in music being influenced by the devil
was Lucifer the head of the choir in
heaven and if so would that explain the
current music situation and how it is a
big influence for people in the world
yeah the closest thing I can think of
where it talks about Lucifer and it
doesn't use the name Lucifer but it's
obviously talking about the devil before
his fall is in Ezekiel chapter 28 and if
you go to oh verse 13 it says you were
in Eden the Garden of God every precious
stone was your covering and it says the
Sardis the topaz the diamond the Braille
the Onyx The Jasper the sapphire
turquoise the emerald with gold the
workmanship of your timbrals which is a
musical instrument and pipes were
prepared for you on the day you were
created so here's this Angel created
that has one of his temporals and pipes
it's kind of uh Old Testament poetic
word for saying though your voice
uh and believe that you know if Angels
Sing
and the Bible tells this Angel saying
you know the Angel's saying when Jesus
was born that if Angels Sing the chief
of the Angels would logically have one
of the greatest voices and so this is
one verse that mentions the the musical
sound of his voice or his musical
ability that's probably there might be
another one I don't know of another well
just to clarify that uh verse 14 clearly
says you are the anointed cherub that
covers so we are talking about this
angel in heaven so this there's no doubt
and as being the leader of the Angelic
host uh you would assume he would be
leading them in music and song and
worship and praise prior to his full so
hope that helps Raquel a little bit we
do have a study guide or we actually
have a DVD you can watch for free online
called Cosmic conflict talks about
Lucifer and the fall of Lucifer
all right next color that we have is
Robert listening in Washington Robert
welcome to the program
thank you Pastor Ross uh good evening
Pastor Bachelor evening
thanks for calling uh yes happy New Year
happy New Year thank you
I suppose you uh gotten this question
before or or heard uh something like it
um about second Corinthians 12 and uh
Paul experiencing the in in of in body
and Out of Body Experience someone
earlier today was was suggesting that
was a near-death experience that he was
out of body
yeah well when Paul and let me read it
for our friends that are listening this
is in second Corinthians chapter 12
verse 1 it is doubtless not profitable
for me to boast I'll come to visions and
Revelations of the Lord I Know a Man in
Christ who 14 years ago whether in the
body I do not know or whether out of the
body I do not know God knows such a one
was caught up to the third heaven
and so he's probably referring to
himself in the second person saying I
had this Vision I had a revelation
I was caught up to God whether I was
physically there whether it was taken in
the spirit John in chapter 4 of
Revelation he says I was caught away in
the spirit
uh it was so real to Paul he just he
didn't know was I there or was it in the
spirit and it felt maybe tangible but
God could have taken him out of body and
it would have felt tangible so you know
God can give a person a
three-dimensional dream where you smell
and taste and touch
and yet it may be a spiritual experience
so I think that's what Paul is at is
talking about there I don't what are
your thoughts yeah I don't think there's
any reference to any of death experience
actually he's going on he's talking
about visions and Revelations so of
course Paul was a prophet he received
visions and we have many examples of the
Bible in the Bible of people who
received versions or a prophecy Daniel
the whole book of Daniel you have a
number of visions and of course that's
not near-death experiences and Paul's
probably talking about himself in the
first few verses because you go to verse
7 and he says lest I should be exalted
above measure by the abundance of the
revelations he said I had so many
Revelations and Visions God spoke to
Paul on several occasions or Jesus did
anyway that um he said you know unless I
should boast I was given this Affliction
so he's probably referring to himself in
the first few verses okay he might have
been having a bout with his Affliction
that's why I said I knew a man second
person
all right we've got Susan listening in
Wisconsin Susan welcome to the program
taking my
I can share your program with many of my
friends on Facebook
um somewhere in England and in other
places in the world
um my concern is the emphasis put on the
pagan holidays and the Pagan traditions
of men
you know like many people we used to
you know do Christmas and Easter and
Halloween and all that until
um a while back I started delving into
the history of it
and I was shocked
um
that Jesus was born in The Landing
season it had nothing to do with
December 25th
um
well first Susan put this into the form
of a question
oh I'm sorry okay
um the form of the question hmm
um how can we stay away from
being drawn in with you know Pagan
Traditions when we know in the Bible
it doesn't instruct us to do that okay
good I appreciate that and I think I
know you're coming from so in our
culture today there are a number of
holidays and sometimes they're called
Christian holidays where there's no
Bible command to celebrate the birth of
Christ there's no Bible command to
celebrate his resurrection
um so what do we do where we see that
even the pagans had holidays where the
25th of December they would sort of
celebrate the the end of winter and the
birth of the Sun
and uh
Christian Church years ago decided that
that was the date that they were going
to assign for the birth of Christ and
and uh trying to exploit the Chris or
the pagan holiday that way how do you
respond to that as a Christian first of
all Paul said in Romans 14 uh if one man
regards one day above another another
man regards every day alike Let each one
be persuaded in his own mind if you're
going to keep a day keep it to the Lord
don't keep it to Santa Claus and elves
and reindeer and all that if you're
going to memorize or if you're going to
memorialize the resurrection then don't
you know have it all about Easter
bunnies and eggs and so forth it should
be thanking God for the resurrection of
Jesus by the way Jesus while he wasn't
born the 25th of December he was
resurrected around the time of the
Passover so the time of Easter is at
least closer than the time of Christmas
I'd say if you if you don't feel that
way then don't there's no command you
know and
you know I think there is a possibility
where we as Christians could exploit for
example these holidays I'm thinking
about Christians for example when uh
most of the world is talking about the
birth of Jesus we recognize and I think
there's a lot of evidence that Jesus was
not born the 24th of December just
because of the the weather in the Middle
East and Jerusalem and that kind of
thing they weren't there wouldn't be
Shepherds out in the field but when
people are thinking about it uh what an
opportunity for us to share Jesus with
those who have never really come to know
him so you know Paul says to the Jew I
became a Jew so that I could win some
for Christ to the Gentile I became a
gentile to win those for Christ now of
course we don't violate our conscience
but we can exploit these opportunities
to try and share truth now I think out
of the holidays Pastor Doug one that as
Christians we would probably have a
really hard time with where I don't
think there's any good or any redeemable
aspect and that would be Halloween now
that's new to me where I grew up we
didn't do Halloween but when I came to
the US wow this is a strange holiday
were you celebrating ghosts and goblins
and skeletons so I think for a Christian
when it comes to Halloween that's
probably one of the hardest and dry it's
it's hard to kind of pull out anything
good from that from that holiday yeah I
remember we went out uh Christmas
caroling years ago in a small town and
and I was a young Christian and with a
small group from our church just singing
Christmas girls and one family opened
the door and some kids were standing
there they looked very sad and the
family says we don't believe in
Christmas and he shut the door and I
thought
okay well that's not a really great way
to witness during the holiday so I would
say now and for um Susan
uh or anyone
because something is Pagan doesn't
always mean it's bad what I mean by that
is Pagan just means that it's not of a
Christian origin there's a lot of pagan
things we do in our culture that aren't
essentially bad the thing is if there is
a pagan law or custom that violates a
Christian principle don't do that
and uh you know nothing of the Bible
talks about shaking hands they used to
greet each other with a holy kiss well
we don't do that we shake hands there's
nothing sinful about shaking hands you
know what I'm saying so that's because
there's a custom that may have a pagan
origin doesn't necessarily mean it's bad
unless it violates a Christian principle
that's an important point now we do have
a book we can offer Susan called baptize
paganism that's right and she will
appreciate that saying that to anyone
who calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
it's called baptized paganism you can
also dial pound 250 and say Bible
answers live and then ask for the book
baptize paganism we've got Johnny
listening from Texas Johnny welcome to
the program
hello pastors is my first time calling
in um just a little background I've been
doing Bible studies for about 15 years
getting my graduate degree in it
um over the course of doing Bible
studies I have a quick question for you
um in John 3 13 it says no man has
ascended into heaven except for the
except for I who came down from heaven
but yet you have Enoch who walked with
God he was no longer then you had Elijah
who was taken up to heaven in a
whirlwind even though he writes a letter
to jerraham afterwards right so I just
wanted to get your take on this
yeah I don't think that Jesus is
referring to Enoch or Elijah or even for
that medal Moses had been resurrected at
this point as well he's basically saying
that there had been no human that had
come from the presence of God to Earth
to bring that knowledge of the father
except him
shrew Elijah was caught up to heaven and
Enoch walked with God and he was not for
God took him but there was no Heavenly
messenger who had come from the presence
of God to Earth to live among men and
teach other than Jesus yeah and I think
the context of that pass today if you
look at the earlier verse Jesus said if
I've told you Earthly things and you do
not believe how would you believe if I
tell you Heavenly things so it's in the
context of teaching right and then Jesus
says no one has ascended to heaven and
come back down
in order to give this or to reveal
Heavenly things but the Son of God right
or himself so that's the context not
saying that no one is ever ascended up
into heaven it's also interesting that
Moses and uh well of course Moses was he
died in his resurrected and taken to
heaven then you have Elijah that was
taken they did appear on the Mount of
transfiguration with Jesus
too that's right that is interesting but
they didn't come to teach right things
that they had heard in heaven Jesus came
they didn't talk to humanity they just
talked to Jesus right right yeah good
point I hope you have it thanks Johnny
let's see uh Chelsea listening in
Florida Chelsea welcome to the program
hi Pastor dag and Pastor Ross how are
you great
yeah so my question basically so right
now I'm currently attending Graduate
School uh for veterinary medicine and
many of my professors believe in and
teach concepts of evolution so I wanted
to know as a Christian how can I be an
effective witness to my professors who
believe in evolution and also are there
any resources that you have that I can
share with them that shows them that
God's biblical creation is actually true
all right two questions uh one first
I'll answer we do have a little sermon
book if they're open to read it and it's
it's called when Evolution flunked the
science test you might want to read it
first they may think it's too Elementary
for their sophisticated level of study
it's basically written for just Layman
to read and say that you know Evolution
doesn't really
make sense
um in visiting with them now we have
some videos online I've got a video that
you can listen to It's a YouTube where
it talks about Evolution creation and
logic
and I used to be an evolutionist and I
became convinced about creation because
I believe that Evolution was very
unscientific
I started seeing that it just was really
illogical to believe that you could get
order and organization and inner working
systems and symbionic relationships
by accident
there had to be intelligence to have all
of this incredibly complex interaction
of life in our planet and just the way a
cell works and the way that uh you know
life works is is extremely complex for
that to have happened without an
intelligent God is absurd
so I don't know if you'd say that to
your professors so I think the best
thing to do is pray for them be a
witness and if they're open share
information there are some other really
good resources out there by a Ministry
called Answers in Genesis their
specialty is uh material about creation
and evolution and we recommend them
wholeheartedly and you know pass it I
get is interesting that there are a
number of non-Christian scientists that
are looking at at least darwinian
Evolution and saying if Darwin knew what
we know now about DNA and about the cell
uh it just there's just no way yeah it
would make sense and yet people are
still holding on to the idea of
evolution I mean there's things like a
sudden explosion of diversity of life
that they see in the fossil record where
there's no intermediate forms of of
animal life but suddenly there they are
with the full DNA that cannot be
explained by darwinian Evolution yeah
even to have the simplest form of life
is extremely complex I read somewhere
that Darwin was confounded by the
complexity of the eye whether human eye
Eagle Eye whatever it is and he said
that just he could never find that
satisfactory explanation explanation for
the eye
anyway here we are out of time but do
ask for that book Chelsea when Evolution
flunked the science test then I'm going
to call for that is
800-835-6747 the book is called how
science flunked how Evolution flanked
the science test and we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls an
so you can dial pound 250 Bible answers
live and say I want the book how
Evolution flanked the science test yeah
now for our friends listening we are
going to sign off in two stages we're
bidding farewell to our friends
listening on satellite but for the rest
of the audience stay tuned we're coming
back in just a moment with some of your
Internet Bible questions
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends welcome back for those of
you who are able to stay with us we're
going to take some of your email
questions and if you'd like to send us
an email question our email address is
just Bal questions at
amazingfacts.org that's balquestions
that
amazingfacts.org Pastor Doug first
question that we have for tonight if
there are going to be no marriages or
new births in heaven will there be
marriage as a new birth in the new Earth
well I would think that uh what happens
in heaven continues in the new Earth now
God told Adam and Eve to be fruitful
multiply and fill the Earth so I think
King James uses the word replenish that
leaves us with the idea that Earth was
once populated got wiped out and they
had to replenish it no it just means to
fill
and so um
once the Earth is full of the redeemed
there'll be no need for procreation
otherwise think about the the math and
pretty soon people would be on top of
each other like rabbits spilling off the
planet into empty space there'd be no
room so the Earth is going to be
populated with the redeemed Jesus is
making mansions for everybody and we'll
go out and build our own Mansions but
there'll be no procreation as their
children that have died or children
alive when Christ comes will go to
heaven and it says they'll go forth and
grow up and that's in Malachi chapter
four okay another question that we have
it says what did Jesus mean in Matthew
20 verse 16 when he said the first shall
be last and the last shall be first well
Christ is making the statement there
talking about the Jewish Nation who he
chose first as a people and gave them
the the truth they might be surprised
that some of the Gentiles who would
embrace the gospel people you know
within the first 50 years of
Christianity there were more Christians
in the world than there were Jews the
gospel had gone like fire through the
Roman Empire
and they embrace it with uh you know
many of course embrace it with their
heart and soul so first he's saying
don't think because you had the gospel
first that you may have first place in
heaven those who appreciate and embrace
it they're going to be the ones closest
to God and so we might be surprised all
right last question Pastor Doug if a
trans person says that they believe in
Christ are they saved
well if a person believes in Christ
they're going to obey the law of the
Lord and the Bible says that a man shall
not wear that which pertains to a woman
and a woman shall not wear that which
pertains to a man all that do so are an
Abomination they'll want to obey hey
friends you hear the music we're out of
time God willing we will study his word
together again next week
amazingfacts.org go to the site
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]